dear ladies and gentlemen biodiversity
means human health
food security and resilience to climate
change
around 66 percent of wildlife
lives on just around two percent of the
earth
and we are losing nature and
biodiversity at an unprecedented rate
we're squeezing nature into smaller and
smaller pockets
and we are paying the price
the more nature is under threat
the more vulnerable we all become
only healthy and diverse forests can
store water carbon
and prevent forest fires
only healthy marine ecosystems
can feed our people and help regulate
the climate
and that is why the world needs to aim
high in montreal for cop15 to adopt an
ambitious global deal for nature
the evidence is overwhelming
but the economic opportunity
is equally compelling
the world economic forum estimates that
over half of the world's output
depends on nature and its services
and by taking better care of nature we
can mitigate and adapt to climate change
often at a very low cost
in fact every euro spent on restoring
damaged ecosystems
can bring us at least eight euros in
return
and this is why since we last met at the
leaders pledge for nature
we have put forward the first ever
european nature restoration law
and new legislation to make sure our
consumption in europe does not drive
deforestation in other parts of the
world
europe is ready to aim high
but we must do this together
and for that i believe we need three key
commitments in montreal
first
an ambitious global framework to stop
and reverse biodiversity loss
and protect 30
of land and ocean globally
second we need measurable goals and
targets
supported by a fair monitoring system to
keep track of progress
and third
we need to scale up biodiversity
financing from all sources public and
private domestic and international
as i announced last year the european
union is doubling its global
biodiversity financing
especially for the most vulnerable
countries
and i encourage all international donors
to live up to the same level of ambition
i know this will not be easy but we can
do it
i call on all leaders to come together
to adopt an ambitious global deal
to protect the biodiversity of our
common home
let's have the courage to do what is
right
and let's do it now
thank you